[Musique]
il fait nuit vous êtes seul chez vous
votre téléphone sonne numéro inconnu
mais vous décrochez quand même et là
vous entendez cette voix d'outre-tombe
allô
oui je vais vous présenter ma
candidature au congrès les républicains
à l'élection présidentielle d'accord
contrôler j'aurais damilano ordre dans
l'abri
au maire est très gourmande le fromage
en tête de liste des péchés mignons
valley visité un marché elle va revenir
les sanitaires le brie de meaux vraiment
alors ça si façon un peu rapide
d'atteindre son coeur tablettes bon bout
pâte à tartiner
avec mes pieds
mais aussi création
plus surprenant
voire même
très surprenante
c'est bien
je me lâche sur le chocolat sans être
écoeuré on est tranquille ça ça passe en
c'est l'apéro à miss à l'apéro du
lâchage c'est la pub là j'y retourne et
là je commence à me dire bon comme
dommages et faire du sport c'est pas
très grave donc je peux peut-être
attaqué la droite non on fait les porter
bah oui un café où il faut faire le
portait alors à quoi il ressemble
[Musique]
mais j'étais instituteur et directeur
d'école j'ai fait trente ans dans les
quartiers nord de marseille ça vous
manque
franchement y'a d'écouté qui vous manque
le
côté rapports humains mais celui qui me
manque le moins c'est aussi le côté le
rapport humain
le chef du camp lui fait même un petit
cadeau vous avez jésus bon pour vous il
parle papier a même le droit à un cours
de catéchisme accéléré ils demandent de
gros et le ressuscité trois jours entrée
et jésus nous a mis
au fond le slam vous l'êtes sur dix est
une façon de commenter aussi l'actualité
parfois et là c'est à la fois une
actualité qui concernait une chanteuse
et une réaction va pas se tait le nom du
journaliste en question parce que moi
j'ai jamais eu envie d'ailleurs j'ai
jamais reçu ce gars là jamais envie de
lui faire de la boj et je me suis de son
bon ben voilà vous avez bien raison
parce que enfin pas content que vous
citiez ses paroles je les ai vus on m'a
dit qu'il était en télé pas longtemps il
s'est bien gardé de dire qu'il était en
train de m'attaquer au japon il ya des
quand même des qualités humaines
fondamentales ne serait ce qu'à la
bienveillance launay dès l'ouverture à
autrui la tolérance qui font qu'on dit
c'est une bonne personne et je crois que
c'est quelque chose d'assez instinctif
quand on voit quelqu'un a aperçu un
homme ou une femme de bien ah c'est pas
quelqu'un qui est animé par la malice la
l'animosité l'arrogance la jalousie etc
il a eu des mots sur la chanteuse o'shea
sur son physique car son but ans lutte
et il a dit qu'elle était effrayante dit
elle a du talent cette chanteuse mais
c'est évidemment il faut vous mais
qu'elle écrive pour des filles sublimes
donc voilà puis après il a toute une
notion de ce que devrait être un
chanteur ou une chanteuse aujourd'hui
qu'est incroyable et du coup à moi j'en
ai fait une chanson pleine d'ironie qui
s'appelle des gens beaux parce que c'est
lui c'est sa phrase il a dit il faut des
gens beaux donc on a repris sa pour en
faire un refrain très dansant sur ces
photos on voit que j'avais un problème
que ma mère m'a pas reprocher à disait
tu avais une trop grosse tête par
rapport au reste du corps tête un clip
plutôt pouvez toujours sur la télépathie
dans sa mère assurer les enfants dans la
famille lemoine vous savez ce que me
disait ma mère dont
je prie le malheur de d'aller la voir
pour me rassurer je fais maman est ce
que je suis beau bar et produits non
t'es quelconque et ça calme je suis
content on a réussi a pas cité son nom à
ce pique assiette donc
ma mère adore juin un rapport et un
humour très particulier quand je criais
dans la maison maman ma maman à l'autre
bout du pavillon à crier elle est morte
donc
la concession pour sa tortue a coûté
plus cher que celle de son mari décédé
l'an passé pour cinq ans j'ai payé 555
euros alors que pour 15 ans pour claude
c'est 290 euros oui c'est cher mais je
pense quand on aime on compte pas on va
nous prendre peut-être pour des
illuminés dire oh vous gâcher votre
argent mais non je pense pas je pense
que gaëtan le mérite des animaux de
compagnie c'est vrai que non non non un
enfant c'est très bien
ce qu'ils ont été vous savez des équipes
aux confins dit non non je sais ce n'est
pas de la compagnie essaie de l'amour
surtout
c'est bon j'ai rattrapé ça passe
avec des femmes
même les chats sont déjà
je rappelle qu'un enfant n'est pas un
animal domestique
il serait d'accord
animal domestique est propre
c'est beaucoup
l'odeur de kaka c'est un conte quelqu'un
quand même vous rendez sympathique
marine le pen vous contribution à peine
n'est pas pour valérie pécresse finale
inquiète à chaud pourquoi toujours les
mêmes pourquoi les journalistes vous me
demandez est ce que n'avait pas peur
d'humaniser marine le pen pourquoi vous
ne demandez pas est-ce que je n'ai pas
peur de la tique anne hidalgo est ce que
vous voulez regarder toute sympathique
ahl par les rangs mais elles sont tout à
lui même nous apparaissent tous sous un
jour favorable laissé leurs voix c'est
leur jour à elle c'est leur ego nathalie
diamond a raison mais vous les
agricultrices je suis rassuré je vais je
trouver un mec
cecobois titeux mais je peux pas
plus surprenant l année dernière les
utilisateurs français d'alexa ont 10 4
millions et demi de fois je t'aime
directement à leur assistant vocal alors
pas sûr que ce soit très sincère et
c'est pas des monstres froids il va
falloir peut-être ça se dire que les
journalistes aussi sont peut-être
responsables aussi de cette défiance
qu'on a vis-à-vis des politiques à trop
vouloir tout le temps les caricaturer
entre elle est hystérique elle et c'est
un monstre froid elle elle décide de
tout mais mais en fait on ne s'en sort
pas se dire à tout le temps s'opposer
aux politiques et à toujours vouloir les
dm déshumaniser les gens ne votent plus
haut si elle a vraiment hâte de boxer à
boxer dans le dur il lâche pas
quand tu fais une mauvaise anciennement
où elle n'a pas bien fait pas bien
exécuté là tout de suite je le rappel à
l'ordre avec une petite pique mes moyens
illégaux jeu - hortefeux
a déclenché des tonnerres dit vous avez
réussi à faire craquer michel drucker
jean marc ouais ouais ouais il connard
sylvie dit quelque chose il vous qui
pouvait raisonner se servir et je me
suis dit voilà
wallon à jean denim au
[Rires]
chili
vous dire qu'il ya des mamies qui vont
faire des drôles de rêves ce soir